RELIGION AND IT DRIVES THEIR
DECISION-MAKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US TONIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, EVEN CNN DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR ECONOMY
UNDER JOE BIDEN.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE.
WE'RE QUOTING HERE.
THE WORLD MAY BE CAREENING
TOWARD A 1970s STYLE ENERGY
CRISIS OR WORSE AGAIN, CNN.
NOW, JOE BIDEN PLANNING A TRIP
TO THE MIDDLE EAST IS A JUST
MENTION TO BIG SAUDI ARABIA FOR
MORE OIL.
ACCORDING TO JOE, THERE WAS
NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE TO
INCREASE SUPPLY AND BRING DOWN
PRICES.
AS ONE ECONOMIST ON CNBC
EXPLAINS, THAT'S NOT REALLY
ACCURATE.
WATCH.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST DRIVERS O
THIS SURGE HAS BEEN ENERGY, AND
THERE ARE CONCRETE STEPS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION COULD BE
TAKING TODAY TO START BRINGING
DOWN SOME OF THE MEDIUM TO
LONGER RUN PRESSURE ON ENERGY
PRICES.
IF THEY WANTED TO BRING DOWN TH
NEAR-TERM PRICE OF PRESSURE,
THEY COULD ISSUE SOME WAIVERS,
WE'RE NOT SEEING THEM DO THAT
BECAUSE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNAVOIDABLE.
>> THE RULE ABOUT SHIPPING, WHY
BASICALLY REFINERS IN HOUSTON
HUNT POINTED BECAUSE THESE WEIR
SHIPPING REGULATIONS,.
>> SO THERE ARE CONCRETE STEPS.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION AS
FORMER ENERGY SECRETARY IN
FORMER TEXAS GOVERNOR RICK P WH
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HER
TONIGHT, CONCRETE STEPS THAT
COULD BE TAKEN ARE AVAILABLE,
YET THEY WILL NOT AND CANNOT DO
IT IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHY?
>> I THINK YOU HEARD THE
REASONING AND THE EARLIER
SECTION WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEY BELIEVE IN THIS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT $6 GAS WILL
PEOPLE FROM ALL IT'S DONE IS
KILLING THE MIDDLE AND LOWER
CLASS IN THIS COUNTRY.
I WENT TO A RECYCLING FACILITY
OVER IN FAYETTE COUNTY, TEXAS
AND A GUY THAT STARTED IN HE
SAID LOOK, AND THIS IS A GUY
WHO'S WORKING 8-10 HOURS A DAY
PUTTING IN LOTS OF HOURS AND NO
MAKING MUCH WAGES, GOING TO THE
GROCERY STORE AND GOING TO THE
GAS PUMP AND HE'S HAVING TO MAK
A DIFFERENCE, HE SAID I'VE GOT
TO FILL UP HALF IN MY TANK AND
MY TRUNK BECAUSE I'VE GOT TO BU
FOOD FOR MY FAMILY.
HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M ABOU
TO BELIEVE THE ONLY PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT OUR DEMOCRATS
ARE THE RICH BECAUSE US FOR
FOLKS, WE ARE DONE WITH IT.
AND I THINK THAT WAS A REAL
STATEMENT ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENIN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN AND ALL HIS RICH
FRIENDS, ALL THAT WOKE LEFT,
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT $6 A
GALLON FOR GASOLINE, THEY THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING, BUT IT'S
KILLING AMERICA AND YOU HURT A
LITTLE EARLIER, THAT NOVEMBER I
GOING TO BE A MOMENT OF
RECKONING IN THIS COUNTRY AND I
SHOULD BE.
WE COULD BE MAKING SOME CHANGES
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE
KNOW HOW TO DO THIS, THEY KNOW
YOU GET THE PERMITTING PROCESSE
DEBT, YOU OPEN UP THE OIL FIELD
BACK UP IN ALASKA.
YOU GET OUR OFFSHORE LEASING
GOING.
YOU SEND A MESSAGE TO THE OIL
AND GAS I KNOW WILDCAT IS, IF
THEY THINK THEY CAN MAKE A BUCK
OUT THERE, THEY ARE GOING TO GO
RISK THEIR CAPITAL AND DO WHAT
IT TAKES THEY ARE NOT SEEING
THAT TODAY, THE ESG CROWD AND
THE CORPORATE ENTITIES, WE DON'
LIKE FOSSIL FUELS, SPEAKING OF
FOSSIL FUEL, AND WANT TO END
WITH THIS, THERE IS A GREAT NEW
BOOK OUT THIS WEEK THAT IS
CALLED FOSSIL FUTURE FIVE, I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND PEOPLE GO GET
COPY OF THIS AND READ IT.
IT MAKES THE CASE ABOUT IF YOU
CARE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS
WORLD, YOU BETTER CARE ABOUT
FOSSIL FUELS AND THE USE OF
THOSE, NOT ONLY TO KEEP AMERICA
SAFE FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
STANDPOINT, BUT ALSO, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BRING PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AROUND THE WORLD,
LITERALLY BILLIONS OF PEOPLE AR
COUNTING ON FOSSIL FUELS TO DO
IT.
YOU EITHER HATE THESE PEOPLE AN
DON'T CARE IF THEY DIE OR YOU
NEED TO GET ON THE FOSSIL FUEL
BANDWAGON.
>> I WANT TO DIG INTO THAT,
GOVERNOR BECAUSE THE IDEA OF
INTENTIONALITY.
THEY WANT IT TO HURT, BECAUSE I
IT $6 A GALLON, 650, $7, THEY
ARE FORCING TO PEOPLE TO BE NOT
JUST PINCHED, BUT SQUEEZE AND
THEN CHANGE THEIR LIVELIHOODS,
LESS DRIVING, LESS CONSUMPTION,
HOW DO YOU RATIONALLY.
IS IT REALLY AS SIMPLE AS AND I
GRAPPLE WITH THIS MYSELF, THEY
ARE SO OBSESSED WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THIS RELIGION OF
THEIRS THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO
BRING THIS ECONOMIC PAIN AND TH
SHORT-TERM KNOWING IN THE LONG
TERM THEY COULD HAVE THE CONTRO
THEY WANT.
>> THEY THINK THEY CAN DRIVE
PEOPLE TO THE RENEWABLE SIDE OF
THINGS.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE KNOW IS
THAT ALL OF THE ABOVE'S BREAK.
WE MOVE THE BIG INTO THE WIND
ENERGY BACK IN THE EARLY 2000,
IT WAS A GOOD THING, BUT IT'S
NOT TO TAKE OVER FOSSIL FUELS.
YOU NEED ALL OF THE ABOVE.
YOU NEED NUCLEAR GREAT IF WE
DON'T GET THE NUCLEAR ENERGY
GOING IN THIS COUNTRY AND AROUN
THE WORLD, WE ARE DONE.
YOU CAN'T DO IT WITH JUST WIND
IN SOLAR.
ALL YOU'LL DO IS HAVE BLACKOUTS
IN THEN YOU'RE GOING TO REALLY
FIND OUT WHATEVER WORKS THE BES
CAN RISE TO THE TOP.
PRESSING ONE IN PARTICULAR AND
MAKING PEOPLE FEEL PAIN, THAT I
IDEOLOGICAL.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE WILLING TO
DO IT RIGHT GOVERNOR, WHERE DOE
THIS GO?
WHERE DOES IT GO IN THE YEAR OR
TWO WITH PEOPLE MAKING THE
DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO FILL UP
A HALF TANK?
>> NOVEMBER IS GOING TO BE A BI
TURN OVER BREAK I THINK YOU'RE
NOT ONLY GOING TO SEE THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES GO IN A BIG
WAY, MAY BE THE MOST SUBSTANTIA
CHANGE OF SEATS AND THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY.
I THINK THE SAME THING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THE SENATE WHERE
YOU'VE GOT THAT TYPE OF
LEADERSHIP CHANGE AND AT THAT
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME, YOU
CAN SEND A MESSAGE TO THE WHITE
HOUSE, YOU ARE OUT OF LINE AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS COUNTRY
BACK AND WE'RE GOING TO GET
FOSSIL FUELS BACK WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE GLOBALLY, THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, I LOOK FORWAR
TO READING THAT BOOK.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF
NATURAL RESOURCES RIGHT IN OUR
OWN HOME SOIL IF WE ARE WILLING
TO UNLEASH IT.
AND THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE